(audience cheering)
Hey, Drew.
You are one of my favorite chefs on this planet.
I'm actually like, melting over here, thank you.
You deserve to be,
I've been such a fan of yours for years.
Okay, I'm so excited.
By the way, I'm gonna show a picture.
This is my kitchen, by the way.
This is some of my cookbook collection,
your cookbook, "L.A. Son",
and these are all your sauces.
And I have to say, Roy Choi, you've done it once again.
They were the best sauces I've ever had in my life.
And funny enough, I combined two
in the dish 'cause I was slurping it up
and they all started to run together.
First, they were neatly in their corners
and as I grazed, it all coagulated, I'm salivating.
That's so awesome, that's exactly,
I mean, you did exactly what I wanted folks
to do with these sauces.
Because we created these sauces to be almost like crayons.
You could do anything you want with them.
They're really easy, you just pour them together,
you make your own sauce out of the sauces.
And that was the whole idea behind everything.
And I'll show you how easy it is.
So the first one is the Korean BBQ Marinade.
So for you as a cook, all you got to do is pour it over.
You just pour it over and mix it.
So I think you already have some cooking over there.
I had some going already, but I want to show you,
so this is, I just poured this over right now.
And then this is after a couple hours right here
and you see how it's broken down.
And then what we wanna do
is just put that right on the griddle.
But yeah, so you just wanna grill this up
and then as it's grilling,
you wanna add these onions and cilantro.
So this is just chopped onions, chopped cilantro, lime juice
and a little bit of salt.
Oh my gosh, this smells so good.
Wanna put that in there?
Great, right?
Doesn't it smell amazing?
Perfect, I'm right there with you.
And then, so now we're gonna let that kind of do its thing
and we're gonna move over
and we're gonna start our quesadilla here.
Okay.
Put the quesadilla on the griddle or the pan.
And then go ahead.
And then go ahead and layer your cheese over the top.
We'll do a nice generous layer.
You know, I like food messy.
Thank God.
And it's okay to go around the edges.
Almost, I encourage going outside the lines here
and just letting it kind of like fall off the edges.
So you got to keep an eye on your tortilla.
What we're looking for here
is obviously you want the cheese to melt,
but what we want on the bottom here,
we want to create these blisters within the tortilla.
And then now what we're gonna do, take that cooked meat,
and let's go over one side of it, kind of like a half moon.
And then now once you do that,
we're gonna flip it over.
And then once you flip it, give it a nice press.
We're gonna flip it.
Woo, look at you, every time you flip it,
I want you to give it a little press.
Give it a little love press like that.
Yeah.
I'm spanking mine.
Again, keep pressing it.
And then now we're almost ready.
Let's go over to the cutting board, look at that.
Okay, we're gonna go to the cutting board.
And then at the cutting board,
We're gonna cut this thing into four slices.
So just cut right down the middle
and then cut the halves again.
Oh, you're doing great, you're doing fantastic,
look at that.
There you go, and just think pizza slices.
Oh my god.
Mm, mm.
So there you go.
And then what we wanna do is we have our orange chili sauce.
Mm-hm.
And just drizzle right over the top.
Just drizzle over the top.
I'm going a little Jackson Pollock splatter art,
I don't know why.
There you go.
And then you can garnish if you'd like
with some cilantro.
And then that's your Kogi short rib sweet chili
quesadilla.
Now, is it okay if I taste this?
Yes.
Oh my, oh my God.
Thank you.
Well, that's it, look how beautiful that is.
Thank you so much.
Roy Choi, you have been my hero since I was, hold on.
(audience laughs)
Yeah?
(laughs) I love your food so much.
Roy Choi, it is an honor and a pleasure
to finally make your acquaintance as a huge fan
and an LA girl.
Oh my gosh.
Thank you so much.
For this recipe and to get your Kogi sauces,
which will change your life,
go to thedrewbarrymoreshow.com.
Roy Choi, it is an honor, let this be the first of many.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
(upbeat bright music)